oh don't leave vegan Jasmine to poop
over them couldn't Jasmine to poop it's
Joyce your girl hi I'm Jasmine and today
I'm gonna be listening to a bunch of
different European languages and
determining which one is the sexiest I
have a PhD in all the sex appeal in
languages so I feel confident I studied
French in college for four years I've
actually been to Paris which was nice
the culture is great the food is great I
really love France I've been to Europe a
few times I've been to Spain Switzerland
Austria all right so let's bring on the
first year pin Rosa I won't go over my
ponytail come on bring it daddy
this Romania I'm so shy what's here free
girls of you thought okay Boonen
dragomir spare catus in spinner
what is the one most fair that's another
good side don't know mister oh sure Wow
jackpot FAMAS I should do I just pulled
over click on new battery we put my
shyness ball up and Christopher Gattelli
card I'm sorry Teresa Mossad Cove Intel
upendra Colossus been way more than that
I know let me give you this story
she's a spying she's sending me a secret
message you know we can't talk to each
other I can't look at each other so we
just have these one small recordings
that are liking the little pen in the
invisible ink I have never heard this
language it almost sounds Russian
secreto das then how did you raise down
she has been Athena she was all cowards
Adam
this is the love of my life oh don't
leave let's bring on your pan number two
mr. Italy oh he's getting comfy on the
bus yeah
Quinn sorry good we have Ishiguro
VistaVision oh yes come italiano
okay our banner well it was didn't
swallow an unprovable after that see no
window this is ordinary scarce oh boy
all my scalp is since I got seen it will
be is again let me start or a booster
don't bother oh but then it was him a
snow bunny see do not build up my goes I
issue this is the kind of dude that
destroys your life you know please what
yeah the one that you said it's it's
it's just like staring at you I have
dreams I'm gonna go to Ivy League school
I'm gonna be the fattest in the world
and then before you know what three
months later you're pregnant
my hands are really sweaty Bengal bellow
you like that mm-hmm
what else do you like I can't say on
camera oh I think I've heard enough
okay thank you vice you okay gasps yeah
sure they're more doable
mmm adobo Ciao Bella Oh bring on the
next one miss Portugal
[Music]
oh I'm user Oh and so sorry ECOWAS
mm-hmm can you see the key booty cache
say it's a large tourist service of
other more elaborate when you come in
together
Louise each day my leuwen new saucers
just looking for Antonia Carter scare
you know what this reminds me of like a
film a film where it's just like the
bright like movie girl but like the long
whispers said we need to stay with that
me as me Jesus abused her laugh was sexy
he was only so much no I think she said
it was so nice to meet you you're the
best person I've ever met
[Music]
let's bring back to Europeans
oh my gosh pretty I'm so scared that
experience was fun I love learning about
languages I love hot people the three
languages that I heard today one was
Romania killing it
number two was Italian of course and
number three was Portuguese because I
saw the Brazil dramas okay let's see the
first one felt like I was running away
with someone who will you know I really
loved and was like I'm not gonna listen
to what the world is trying to make me
do the second one was like but the third
one was like oh her laugh is sex you
know as an equal-opportunity ho I just
love hearing languages from all the
countries and today I'm gonna make my
final decision on which paxton is the
sexiest I think the sexiest one was
Portuguese well I think it was her laugh
I'm not doing this again it's too sweaty
it makes me sweat too much and like a
true Gemini I'm gonna say all that sexy
missus heavy quantitative it was nice to
meet all of you
[Music]
you
[Music]